well we could all use a safe and
thrilling escape right now
the number one michael jackson tribute
show in the world is back and rocky
theas is at the strat to show us
how we can join vegas king of pop rocky
all right mj live is back you guys this
is the king of pop
and the vegas himself dallas maker you
are you've been playing this character
for
eight years people it's been a long time
and you know it's it's a great honor to
impersonate michael jackson the greatest
entertainer of all time
undisputed understanding now do you have
the top five greatest michael jackson
songs personally
absolutely what are they okay it really
depends on the mood that's what i say it
depends on what you're feeling like what
my alarm clock
when i wake up don't stop till good
enough mean i'm asleep
it just gets me going uh you know don't
stop too good enough
billie jean yes beat it of course
halloween was just around the corner you
gotta play thriller
and you gotta have the jackson five but
also smooth criminal right now i was
playing and
remember that video i do iconic video
man
that's right that's why we got that we
got the shoes and everything as a matter
of fact
can i teach you a little a little
movement we're gonna go
to michael jackson move for smooth
criminal since it's playing in the
background very easy
okay like this put your feet together
face that way okay okay
and you're just gonna hop put your chin
down and just and hop
there you go there you go you know what
oh my god
scratch that we're gonna try something
else come here okay oh my gosh
so what actually goes into becoming
we're gonna try to lean right now the
iconic lead
what goes into this performance how do
you train for this because these are
these are acrobatic moves mj was doing
you know a lot of exercise girl
squats that's right you got to eat
healthy okay
so every michael jackson salt
billy jean's got yeah
so same thing face that way okay
okay go a little go forward right there
stand right there there you go
and then put your feet together and on
three you're gonna lean okay
one two three
[Applause]
come check us out mj live opens tomorrow
hotel casino wednesday through saturdays
welcome back welcome back i'll send it
back to you guys